When my toddlers saw the crumble cookie box in the trash,
immediately wanted a cookie.
I caved and just decided to make them some.
Rumble specifically requested a pink one,
so I got right to work making the sprinkles.
Started by combining powdered sugar and some vanilla,
heating that up
and then whipping that while gradually adding in more powdered sugar.
I decided on yellow, pink,
and purple for the sprinkles,
and after they were all mixed
I transferred them over to some piping bags,
cut the tips off,
and then pipe my mixture onto baking tray lined with Parchment paper.
I repeated that process with every colour
and let them dry for about two hours.
In the meantime, I made some butter for my cookies and buttercream,
whipped my heavy cream until it separated,
squeezed out all the way, and stood under cold water,
and then got started on making my cookies.
Whipped together the butter,
some egg, sugar, flour,
baking powder, vanilla,
let that go until it came together,
rolled it into little balls before flattening those out.
Repeated that process with all six of my cookies,
and once they were all flattened out,
I transferred them over to my oven,
bake them for about 15 minutes.
While those were cooling, I made a simple buttercream frosting.
Since we're going for a pink cookie,
we turned the icing pink, pipe the icing on the cool down cookies,
spread it evenly, and repeated that with all of my cookies.
This point, my sprinkles were all dried out,
so I cut them up, sprinkled them on both of my cookies.
My toddlers love these, and these were definitely a treat.